now there's something I've left off have
an eye which is that on some days it's
just sugar cold for anyone to buy
sunscreen or buy ice creams I assume
because maybe I close up shop right
or maybe just nobody even visits the me
so therefore I have a restriction on
this right these functions of sunscreen
ice cream they make sense for only
certain values right I'm guessing you
know of the very very limited data that
I've got well it looks like based on
this guy right think about this right
think about what might happen if it was
say 25 degrees 25 degrees if this
equation were true at 25 degrees what
would you expect to happen company ask
you to expect to sell and the answer is
1 right and then if for 24 degrees I
always expected so for and in for 23
degrees I'd expect to sell 9 ok my
function is going haywire right this
thing because of course you don't the
shape of this there's 26 degrees right
so going for with it because it's the
roof and this is temperature
it gives ice cream that's what you
expect you don't want this side to you
you don't want it oh it's getting cold
up for ice creams ok
so therefore this part doesn't look like
it makes sense does it
ok so really what we wanted only this
part of it here so I would say tea by
the looks of it it is very little 26 I
don't guess it could be something
different but based on the data that
I've got that looks like a pretty
reasonable kind of conclusion
what who does like companies would be
dealing with rather more complicated
data than this so they do do that there
they model things and they're trying to
get equations that follow the patterns
that they've got yeah did you sell 20 if
the temperature is 26 degrees can be
snowing minus three follow the Sun so
perhaps I should have taken this one
would that be a better restriction to go
on what is this guy look like yes he
looks up like this right yes it's a
linear function yeah and it's going up
and I have to have a route 27
right because of the way I factorize it
okay so recall based on this I see this
restriction but you remember moving into
more functions and if you're solving a
log function it out popped a a pop the
quadratic right you have two different
parts and they each have different
restrictions so you take the more
restrictive one right so I guess that
would mean this now exists that does I
can't for this part and data better cuz
I I don't want that
yeah I guess so
I guess
my son doesn't have to be positive I
suppose being that I've refuted it this
way anyway so that kind of implies it
right because it's true unless unless
someone's really Shipman like I don't
have enough money can I just buy a half
of the Papa that's okay
so this idea right remember I said at
the beginning you've got darling all
these measurements based on what happens
in life okay and they seem to be related
to each other what's really going on is
they're related to this third thing
these other measurements that's beside
all the rest of them okay so this idea a
measurement that is beside all your
other data is called literally a the
side measurement that's what parameter
means right you might have you've seen
them work you've seen this the prefix
power before right for example the word
parallel that's when two minds are
beside each other right you've seen the
word you see the word parabola the young
this this ball of worth over there it's
Forum it comes from a Latin word that
means thrown right through so if you
throw something right and you just throw
it up in the air straight up and down
you just get a straight line
okay a straight line but if you throw it
beside you that pot that traces out is a
parabola you have to throw it sideways a
paraphrase is a word beside another set
of words that tells you exactly what
that phrase means now this is called a
parameter okay a parameter the study of
using this kind of thing to understand
others is called parametric's
parametric's parametric's understandings
where there are parameters and there are
loads of examples of this all the time
for example did you know TVs cause
obesity did you know that because it's
pretty obvious right if you look at a
country right and you look at how many
TVs it's got and you compare that one to
the level of obesity they rise it
exactly the same time right right so
this is cool now these these numbers
correlate they correlate just like we
saw this correlate they have a
correlation but it's not a causative
correlation right just like ice creams
don't before sunscreen at least I heard
TV stood like radiating out Febres okay
in fact there's a brother or what what
might you guess is the parameter that
work you can say oh why do you think I
would want to get closest to the root of
what's going on oh the irony
yes sir there it is more complicated
turn to something supportive right but
you can see you see how this can be a
parameter a measurement beside all these
other ones that's causing the other ones
to actually do what they do is correct
the more money you guys the more TVs
movie bought and all that you've got the
richer the food you buy a little higher
the chance that you're over even got a
couple examples for you for instance did
you don't the more prosperous a country
is since you're thinking about economic
business studies GDP of course is so the
more prosperous the country is the more
kids that that country has stopped
stopped making money everyone you're
killing everyone okay
clearly not sure what's going on here
what might be what could be a parameter
yeah I probably say something to do with
it more specifically not just quality of
life but length of life the reason why
in modern times and in more prosperous
countries there's a high incidence of
cancer is that because it's because
there's a lower incidence of infant
mortality and dying for other reasons
right people are getting killed by
tuberculosis or the flu or a fever at
Tanja these things are all deadly right
but because we're a long-lived society
or only a period of time which matches
up to our gross domestic product because
the longer you live right we survive
long enough to get cancer okay now you
can see yeah you can see these kinds of
things happen all the time
clam it is right another very common
ground I'm just going to put it there by
itself is time now you won't meet this a
lot in the rest of this course then
you'll have two different things like
say an object is moving so there's its
displacement right how far away it is
from something and then its speed how
quickly it's moving right now those two
things can be related to each other but
really what they're both related to is
the passage of time in a situation okay
so I need to freeze it this way because
when I first met parametric's the idea
of parameters it's like why we this is
simpler right we usually think less
variables is better right like it's it's
it's less complexity right yes it is
less complexity in a sense but it's a
poorer understanding this is a better
understanding what's going on because it
gets to the report in fact in my head
that's what I think of when I think of
the climb up life less sitting for
climbers what's the root cause actually
making this system door does that makes